اما الروايه الروسيه لما يجري في بخموت
فنقلها موقع ريبار العسكري الذي اكد ان
القوات الروسيه تحاصره القوات الاوكرانيه
داخل المدينه من جهتي الشمال والجنوب كما
سيطرت القوات الروسيه بشكل كامل على بلده
كامنكا الواقعه شمال شرقي افدي افكاوى
التي تعد اخر المعاقل التي كانت تخضع
جزئيا لسيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
وفي الجناح الشرقي من مدينه افدي افكا
وفي تطور الميداني الاخر اعلنت الاداره
العسكريه الاقليميه في خيرسون ان القوات
الروسيه قتلت شخصين واصابه سته الاخرين
بعد قصفها منطقه خيرسون 67 مره حيث اطلقت
القوات الروسيه اكثر من 300 قذيفه مدفعيه
ثقيله وصواريخ جراد وقالت الاداره
العسكريه الاقليميه في قيرسن ان القضاء
فاصابت الاحياء والسكن الاحياء السكنيه
والمباني الخاصه والشقق ومنشاه طبيه
وفي المقابل اكلت وكاله نوفاستروسيه
للانبا استهداف القوات الاوكرانيه محطه
كخوفكا الكهرومائيه في خيرسن ونقلت
الوكاله عن قائد حرس المحطه قوله ان قناصه
من الجيش الاوكراني استهدفوا المحطه
ومحيطه بعيره ناريه كبيره